[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dan bickley the
sports columnist radio host on arizona
sports 98.7
fm is back with us vic great to talk to
you again how's morale in arizona
i've never been better dan i tell you
what nothing like a star
superstar like jj watt to make you
conveniently forget a football team that
really
choked a playoff berth that was right in
front of him last year in arizona
so he is the big feel-good story he's
the big rallying point it's a great
public relations move for this franchise
dan
did anybody have any and cling that
arizona was on the radar for jj
no you know we we talked about it but we
kind of assumed a couple of things here
number one that jj
wouldn't want to come to a team that was
kind of not exactly super bowl close
and secondarily the cardinals have a lot
of needs man
and and we just didn't think they'd go
shopping for a luxury item like jj watt
but there's been a lot of stuff going on
behind the scenes deandre hopkins has
been an
active recruiter um you know maybe the
cardinals will go full blast here and
try to get into the desean watson
sweepstakes
that would be something well i did
wonder about that and i know this was
on uh social media yesterday because you
could
send kyler murray back to texas where
he's a legend high school legend there
but do you think that the cardinals
would entertain the possibility of
trying to trade for deshaun watson
uh you know what i would given their
history with the texans i would never
say
no to anything i think it's a little too
much for them to chew off dp but
you know there are serious questions
with kyler murray the kid
flashed but i mean you guys as as a
radio broadcast
you are one of the first to see how
sometimes not relatable he can be
in and how quirky can be communicating
with him and
and he's not exactly this full-blown
leader like they have in buffalo with
josh allen so
to me the quarterback piece in arizona
is tantalizing as kyler murray looks
i i still have a lot of questions about
this kid and how comfortable he's going
to
feel playing in the nfl given his size
and and given his limitations and given
the fact that this offense around him
last year
did nothing if he wasn't taking off and
running with the football
so if i were them i'd i try to make this
whole thing a texans
uh reunion here in arizona i put i'd
throw my head and no doubt about it
i'm also trying to figure out where the
cardinals rank
their super bowl odds didn't change with
the signing of j.j watt
their odds to win the nfc west did not
change whatsoever
no um i still have a lot of question
marks here
i don't know how long you can rely on
larry fitzgerald are you going to keep
the defense together there
deandre hopkins is wonderful but i
i just don't know about this team i
don't know i think they're a spoiler
yeah the uh the thing about this
football team is the signing of jj watt
is great
for a lot of different reasons but the
cardinals didn't have issues on defense
last year
they had hassan reddick and a special
teams guy named dennis garc
combined for over 20 sacks defense
wasn't their issue
the issue is this offense and this head
coach uh in cliff kingsbury who's been
thoroughly overmatched in this in two
years at the helm here
and whether or not this thing is going
to ascend and whether or not
he can build an offense featuring kyler
murray that doesn't
um rely on these helter skelter
scrambles and
that's the big issue and then where are
the wide receivers going to come from
uh this is a team that drafted andy
isabella over dk metcalf
and they're not the only team to miss on
dk metcalf but they've missed on a lot
of guys recently
so there's a lot of issues here that jj
watt does not solve
which is kind of what's interesting
about this but at the same time
they need a a culture creator here in
the worst way they need a guy who comes
in
and sets a level of accountability
because there's not a whole lot of that
around here this team is
is highly penalized um they don't always
show up ready to play on sunday
afternoon so
you know focus is an issue so they need
somebody to get them on point
um given the weird dynamics of the
hierarchy here in arizona
are you are you sold on cliff kingsbury
as the coach
oh absolutely not i mean i i really i
was in on this at the very beginning
uh coming out of what we experienced in
arizona post brucerians
uh the offense under mike mccoy was
about as awful as you could imagine
and that's saying something in arizona
and i think what what
what we all did here was like heck yeah
we'll take a shot on somebody who's got
a
uh renowned offensive reputation in
college but he did it running a system
that doesn't work full-blown in the nfl
so to me cliff kingsbury was a hail mary
it was a swing of the bat
and from what i've seen particularly at
the end of last year i'm just not that
impressed i i
i don't think this thing is gonna work
but who knows if kyler murray has the
kind of year in year three
if he takes a quantum leap he'll take
everybody along with them
you're kind of a buzz kill like we we
i've i've heard that before maybe jj
watt should have spoken to you maybe he
would fire you
up yeah no listen it's i i am fired up
about jj watt
this football team really needed
something to grasp on to
to move past the way last season ended
where they got manhandled by a
injury-decimated 49ers team and then
there was a debacle of a game at the end
of the year
against the rams both times they win
they get in the playoffs and
and they were at their very worst so
yeah i've got a lot of cause for concern
but i am very happy that there's
something
positive to rally around here we've also
got chris paul and he's been
terrific in phoenix uh do you like the
chances of the suns better
than the cardinals i do i think
if deandre ayton can round into a player
who has
um who can sort of end the passivity
and the uh and if he can play with a
little more ferocity
i think this team has got a real shot
they got a couple of guys in the final
five minutes of a playoff game
in chris paul and devin booker who can
light you up and they can get these
games to a finish line
and i think the depth of talent around
them right now is good enough that
they're going to be in this game um
yeah i think they got a shot at the
western conference finals
i'm going to have to have you on uh you
know as we get closer to the nfl
playoffs then
the cardinals are in the playoffs and
then see what you think
i hope you're right you know i'm always
here for you dp thank you dan that's uh
dan bickley the sports columnist radio
host on arizona sports 98.7 fn
vic great to talk to you again thank you
buddy